how's it going everyone my name is beer
bar and I'm back finally it's been
almost like three freakin miles or
something feels like it's like forever
how do you miss me
I miss you anyway I'm making this video
to say hi I guess and to talk about some
updates I have some good news it's
freaking hot in here I'm not gonna strip
for you guys I promise maybe in another
video anyway the first good news is that
I am now a YouTube partner through
machinima which is great news it's
fantastic and it was kind of like
anti-climatic when it happened it was
like it's supposed to be like yeah but
it was what I K alright because it was
supposed to process like two months ago
so widely finally happening okay but
it's actually looking back it was it's
been a dream of mine like my dreams are
finally coming true not really well sort
of but I I remember like when I started
making YouTube and I saw videos like
this one like people announcing their
becoming partner and I was dying of
jealousy I was like I couldn't bear to
watch what a douchebag he's a douche
anyway right so I hope no one feels that
about me I'm not making this video to be
a douchebag but I'm making it to thank
you guys because
it does really mean a lot and it yeah I
guess that was bad I'm really happy
about it
it's really cool yeah
if I say something about it one more
time it would be awkward it's really
awesome
anyway the second good news is that I
got a new website now it's PewDiePie de
is a German domain because it's not in
Germany or any way anything is so it's
fine like it really doesn't matter but
the guy who made it for me I'm curious
which he really found me early on like I
remember I remember I like I don't know
I don't remember um cakes it's funny cuz
everyone clings they know me in some
freaking weird way like I remember even
what one guys said I've been subscribed
to PD for two years I'm his biggest fan
and it's like I only made videos for six
months so anyway yeah I got a website
it's really cool please go there and
sign that sign up or whatever and we can
have some pity pie time you know gives
me an office time I don't know it it'd
be really cool I like the website like
it's it's been there for a while but
I've been in it was me and I wanted it
to be like and it is right now so if you
know what I'm talking about
then go there but then no one will go
there so if you don't know what I'm
talking about go there yes good let me
go see ya
partner website I guess that was pretty
much it if you want you can also check
out my Facebook and Twitter I'm really
active there it's a lot of fun and other
than that it's good to be back I'll see
you soon and I won't take any more
breaks hopefully